was geht hier sah max und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wir
spielen heute paco und das ist ungefähr
so viel wie man haut vor der polizei ab
okay leute wir sind gerade im spiel
können hier die möglichkeit auswählen
ein neues spiel zu machen was wir direkt
mal auswählen werden so und da sehen wir
schon wir sind dieses auto und wir
werden von der polizei gejagt und
sterben dabei direkt am anfang
optimalerweise glaube ich nicht zweiter
versuch zweiter versuch ich glaube ja
genau es kommt darauf an sozusagen eine
highscore aufzustellen
bei dem mann von der polizei abbau zu
wir rasen hier um die ecke des
polizeiautos einfach gecrasht vor dem
einkommen wir auch noch und nein sind
gerade selbst gecrasht okay das spiel
ist richtig lustig diesmal ob ich
schaffe es ein bisschen länger vor den
cops abzuhauen ich habe allerdings noch
etwas in petto womit wir auf jeden fall
regeln können falls die neue high school
ich weiß nicht auf die erste nicht
vielleicht nichts mehr wir fahren am
anfang ein bisschen provokant paar
donuts damit die polizei uns definitiv
verfolgen wird ich glaube es macht mir
auch egal das war gerade coolste ist zu
erzählen leute es gab zwei polizeiautos
ineinandergefahren habt ihr es gesehen
leute das läuft nicht wie es euch finden
wir müssten zumindest mal eine minute
abbauen oder sowas sonst kommen wir
nicht weit ich weiß nicht ob man auch
nur auf dem park das herumfahren kann
die karte heißt allerdings mal also so
viel wie einkaufszentrum
deshalb befürchte ich vor das läuft aber
gerade deshalb befürchte ich fast dass
ihr job ist voll schlaf war ja komm
schon der hat mich angestarrt und ich
bin die rück gestorben leute es ist
obwohl gewalt so wirst du es noch mal
neu das war schon ein guter highscore
dafür dass sie das zum dritten mal
spiele das war weniger gut
wir schaffen es jetzt aber wir schaffen
das tor
okay das gesehen deshalb nicht gewinnen
nein so hall leute kommen schon noch und
versucht so komm schon konstant komm
schon kommt wir schaffen es jetzt durch
leute es scheint aber ich zu
funktionieren vielleicht muss ich
einfach selbst ein bisschen mehr
gangster werden damit wir das schaffen
probleme erstmal aus was geht
wir sind bergleute und ich glaube so
gangster die ich jetzt bin ich hoffe man
hört mich unter den meisten wenn einer
weg will muss man ein bisschen eis taut
werden wenn ich schon gangster wind das
eis muss auf meine rist seien definitiv
so kate jetzt bin ich definitiv schon
mehr bereit von drive by mit dem preis
an der riß aber eine sache geht noch
okay so leute ich bin wieder dabei drei
spaß machen natürlich zu zweit
mindestens doppelt so viel spaß dass die
augen voll unnötig da ich so etwas mache
aber problems noch mal aus und wenn es
jetzt nicht klappt dann weiß sie auch
nicht bescheid so volle konzentration
hab ihn nicht gesehen und jetzt jetzt
ist wird rasiert mein hobby neben mir
definitiv am start die polizei hat
leider keine
eine ernsthafte chance uns zu kriegen es
sieht wirklich gut aus habe ich gefühl
sie ist einfach niemand
wow wow ok schade aber das war wie lange
18 sekunden ich glaube man muss einfach
um den zu entkommen schön oft übers über
so grasflächen fahren weil dann dann
checken erst nicht wo alter war das
knapp oh mein gott ich bin ein gangster
leute ich bin ein gangster spinne steckt
ich habe michael vicks classic video und
25 sekunden new high score das gangster
outfits als ich schon mal aus okay wir
machen das jetzt weiter vielleicht muss
vielleicht noch mal ums teilen damit ich
auch christian heiss geschafft die
polizei ist definitiv struggle damit
mich alten buchen mich alten sie zu
fangen
vor fast sechs jahren das bedeutet
wahrscheinlich dass die leute mich zu
sechs gerade gequetscht haben die es
gibt auch noch neue karten wir probieren
aber meine neue karte aus alters- 155
dicke wright das ist ja mal deutlich
mehr angemessen für unseren style für
unseren gangsters teil ohne frage sonst
und dicker cadillac wobei er leute hier
sind gerade ich glaube wir sind auf
einem friedhof und das ist kein cadillac
sondern leichenwagen so zumindest
zusammenpassen mit dem thema friedhof
unterlaufen glaube ich zombies du
glaubst informiert ja es sind zombies
dieses spiel ist definitiv crazy noch
mal kurz eine andere map an meine akku
ist allerdings etwas der geplagt etwas
leer
es hat kann ich nicht garantieren dass
wir noch lange zocken können aber es
wird es definitiv auch gleich noch mal
zeit für ein neues outfit weil ja gerade
accident okay also man kann
wahrscheinlich openworld mäßig rumfahren
ja aber die polizei oder was wie soll
ich denn abbauen wenn ihr neues diesmal
ein versuch mal auf dieser karte dann
probieren wir noch mal eine neue außen
auf den neuen werde ich dann hoffentlich
mit einem neuen zweck
alles alles kaputt machen so highway
haben wir hier das wahrscheinlich
richtig schwierig aber ich teile erst
mal um frau dr
so leute ich bin mit einem ganz neuen
swagger am start
ihr merkt schon warum ich keine caps
trage normalerweise so ich bin alt ich
bin auch so ein pkw alter krass habt ihr
das gesehen wie ich da einfach rein mit
jump den rhein geschickt bin in die
parklücke da gerade so kann schon
ich weiß nicht
ich weiß nicht wie weit ihr dann noch
runter fahren können die ganze straße so
ich weiß immer nach vorne und check aus
wo die grenzen sind ob das ding
irgendwie unbegrenzt ist oder ob da hier
gleich jeden moment der exit kommt bzw
das no exit orchester vorne anscheinend
kommen wir da nicht mehr raus die
polizei ist definitiv schon hinter mir
her aber auf der fahrbahn ist gerade
einfach alles frei der da so können wir
richtig zeit schinden
es kommt doch mal lieber wahrscheinlich
waren sie jetzt alle auf der anderen
seite als ok ich dachte schon kann man
die so leicht austricksen
aber das war mir nahe heißt vor 27
sekunden noch eine letzte karte
probieren wir aus einfach noch mal
ausprobieren arena okay da stehen wir wo
wir können das sogar in rosa ein echter
gangster fährten rosa kicker okay das
ist jetzt der allerletzte versuch falls
man handyakku das überhaupt noch
mitmacht die arena map wird geladen so
und wir fahren los in der arena ball da
hat man ja richtig speed drauf da hat
man richtig speed drauf und die cops die
kommen jetzt mit irgendwelchen krassen
lastwagen und hier vorne fehlt einfach
ein monstertruck what the [ __ ] alter ist
es richtig schwierig irgendwie auf der
auf der offenen fläche
wir probieren auch ein erstes mal zehn
sekunden aber es der versuch das fahrrad
schon sechs von daher dürfte es
eigentlich drin sein
vielleicht habe ich auch schon schon 10
auf der karte geschafft und und 26
sekunden 90 tja leute ich glaube ich bin
zwar gangster aber nicht gangster genug
um meinen eigentlichen wunsch highscore
von einer minute zu knacken
ich hoffe mal das video hat euch
trotzdem gefallen auch wenn ich nicht
mein highscore knacken konnte falls das
der fall war lass mal ein like da und
bis zum nächsten mal wird das gut findet
dass ich so apps spiele sagt mir in den
kommentaren da mache ich vielleicht
öfters